hello welcome we're going to be talking
about books or people or something else
I'm not really sure what this potential
series is going to be yet but in any
case some of you may know me as a
musician but another large part of what
I do is actually I am a student of
religions where I study this well the
study of religions basically and what
I've specialized in primarily is Islam
both historically and today and I
thought it was a good idea to talk about
certain historical maybe literary works
or people that have shaped today's world
and that maybe some people don't know
too much about today I'm gonna be
talking about a book or a literary work
this one called hyah by Nexon and excuse
the pronunciation in fact you're gonna
have to excuse a lot of pronunciations
in this video now this is a novel that
was written in Arabic in the 12th
century AD which is as you know a rather
long time ago and what makes this story
so interesting and special is not just
the fact that it's a very well-written
piece of literature that still holds up
today but also that it sort of brings
together a lot of the philosophical and
theological and also scientific
knowledge that was popular in the Muslim
world at the time it has been argued
that the story played a part in
inspiring the European enlightenment and
I've also heard it referred to as the
most important story that you've never
heard of and I'm at least partly ready
to agree with that and of course a
background knowledge and in some of
these movements and schools of thought
enables you to understand and appreciate
some of its themes more but I would
argue that the universality of a lot of
those themes and as well as the it's
just it's literary qualities makes it
easy for anyone to understand and be
impressed by it I should also point out
that this version that I've read as an
English translation of the story and
that I have not read it in its original
Arabic
[Music]
so the author of this work was an
individual known as open to fail and we
don't know a lot about him actually what
we do know is based on this book as well
as some letter sent by him and to him as
well we know that he was born in what is
today southern Spain known then as
Islander loose or Andalusia and this was
a time when this or intellectual culture
of al-andalus was really flourishing and
there's a whole range of historical
thinkers and figures that were active
around this time people like eben rushed
or avaroa says he's known in the West
the Sufi mystic even Al Arabi as well as
Jewish philosopher Maimonides these were
all people that lived in this region at
this time and were inspired by each
other's works in fact they've been
rushed himself was actually a student of
urban to fail so when we pictured this
place at this time it is really easy to
get a very romantic image of wonderful
architecture and great progress in
intellectual thinking as well as
religious groups living in harmony with
each other and while this is partly true
in some sense the reality of the
situation is of course a lot more
complex in truth the time when even to
fail lived and work was politically very
turbulent the Christian forces were a
constant threat in the north and the
Almohad dynasty had just risen to power
through a political revolution and ruled
by what can be interpreted as a rather
conservative or a strict practice but it
meant to fail nonetheless was educated
as a physician which is also well become
his main occupation later in life even
though if he's mostly known to us
through this book as a philosopher what
is important to point out here is that
deep this sort of
the practice of philosophy and science
or medicine was often intertwined and
that if you studied medicine for example
you studied philosophy as well whether
or not even to fail was specialized in
any other area is is unclear but he's
quoted as saying and this is one of my
favorite quotes of all time that had not
music existed in al-andalus I would have
had to invented myself which shows at
the very least that he had a great love
for music but not necessarily whether or
not he was a musician himself he later
managed to secure a position as court
physician to the caliph abu jakob yusuf
at the heart of the Almohad dynasty in
marrakech and he seems to have had an
incredibly successful career and even
after his death he received a state
funeral which is something that just is
unheard of when it comes to philosophers
at this time but it is in the court of
Marrakesh as a physician that he
authored this novel in question we're
gonna be talking about heavily inspired
by thinkers like eben Cena or Avicenna
Al Farabi
as well as the medical teachings of the
Greek Galen physician Galen and also a
lot of Sufi teachings that were becoming
increasingly popular at the time
all of this would culminates and be
gathered into the story of haya binocs
and which translates to something along
the lines of alive son of aware
the book itself is basically a story
about a man who grows up alone as the
only human on an island and through
different stages in his life fulfills
his potential as a human being so if the
Lord of the Flies is a sort of study in
the ultimate evil and savage nature of
the human soul hiya Ben Jackson is the
very opposite of that instead a meant to
fail argues that every human at his core
is good and can reach a an enlightened
state without the aid of society or
other people the story has a very
interesting opening because it is told
in two different ways in one hai is is
the son of a forbidden marriage in a
nearby kingdom and his mother
desperately sort of sets him out to sea
in a in a box to save him and herself
from the repercussions and this is
obviously very similar to the story of
Moses in the Bible for example the other
version of the opening hai is
spontaneously generated as it's known on
the island which is described in a very
poetic language were sort of clay is
gathered into a body and then the
different organs are sort of naturally
just comes into being spontaneously on
the island the reason behind him--as two
fails decision to tell two different
origin stories is hard to know for sure
but it appears that he is trying to make
a point about the difference between
factual truth and a mythical truth if
you will that the same story can be told
in two different ways one that these
sort of people with proper knowledge and
understanding can can understand and one
that those sort of the general public
who even to fail doesn't have a very
high opinion of us will become known
later can understand this interpretation
seems likely considering some of the
themes and points that are made and
later on towards the end of the book
which we'll get to later
whichever story you accept however the
baby does end up alone
on an island and at this point the two
stories or there's just one narrative
basically once he washes ashore his loud
cries catches the attention of a female
deer widow who feels sorry for him and
threw her Surma turtle instincts decide
to take care of him and from this point
on the door basically becomes his mother
at this early stage for all he knows he
is a deer he he eats with him he sleeps
with them and all the way at this point
the story is very beautiful about the
sort of relationship between man and
nature and hi and his mother deer it
takes care for him eventually though as
it becomes a bit older hi sort of
realizes that he's quite different from
the other deer and from the other
animals on the island he recognises the
nakedness of his body and the fact that
doesn't have any sharp claws or teeth to
defend himself with he basically
realizes that the human bodies is
useless and pretty terrible for survival
however he does recognize that he has a
kind of reasoning power that there is
above most other animals he encounters
he uses this reasoning to find two dead
birds and covers himself with their
feathers he can use the same reasoning
to build weapons to defend himself with
and here even to fail concludes that
what makes humans significant is the
power of thought and reason this is
something that is a great theme in this
book and will be further explored later
in the story now the first major event
of highest life appears when he's seven
years old and at this point the mother
dough that has cared for him for his
whole life at up to that point has grown
old and she eventually dies and in a
very moving and beautiful scene HEIs
standing over his mother's dead body and
he he is confronted with his first real
experience with death something we all
have to go through at one point or
another and like most of us he has a
very hard time grasping it the physical
body of his mother is right there and
she looks exactly the same except it's
not her
something that sort of made her what she
was has left the body and he concludes
that the thing that made his mother who
she was was not her physical body was
something else and something that has
now left her being a very curious boy he
basically decides to dissect his mother
and this is where the medical teachings
of Galen and also probably open to fales
own knowledge as a physician really
comes in because the dissection is
described and very in a very detailed
way with the organs and all the sort of
different aspects of the body of this
doe I eventually finds his mother's
heart and upon inspecting and he
discovers that one of its chambers is
empty he concludes that the soul if you
will must reside here and that the
inanimate state of his mother is caused
by the absence of whatever was in there
before this event marks a turning point
for hi as he goes from being dependent
on his mother to a process and of
self-realization and intellectual
discovery he inspects every inch of the
natural world around him and and sort of
learns to classify different animals
into categories he realizes that there
are many individual deer for example but
they all make up a unified category of
well deer and that there is one animal
but all animals make up one reunified
character of the animal kingdom or
whatever you want to call it he accepts
the Aristotle and concepts of matter and
form and finally he he turns his gaze to
the heavens and the Stars based on the
astronomy of al-farabi and others he
divides the sky into heavenly spheres on
which the stars and planets move on and
sort of exist naturally he wonders
whether the world is infinite or if it's
finite and here he reaches the rather
interesting conclusion it doesn't matter
he argues whether the world is infinite
whatever conclusion we draw they both
lead to the realization of the ultimate
truth which is the existence of God now
remember aimin to fail was after all a
Muslims of course God has a role to play
here and in the novel he refers to God
as the necessary being or necessary
existence a phrasing concept borrowed
directly from the Persian philosopher
eben Xena
also known as Avicenna in the West and
this is a person who he and most other
philosophers at this time were heavily
inspired by so after all of HEIs
contemplations about the nature of the
world through his inspections of the
natural environment around him through
understanding the soul as something
material in the heart to considering its
immaterial nature from worshipping fire
to later lifting his head to the skies
and the heavenly spheres at the end of
all this he reaches the conclusion that
there must be a god unnecessary existent
that is the source of all things now in
the face of it this may not appear to be
a very controversial statement
considering the popularity of this view
both today and also at the time this was
written but consider what happened to
fail is saying here hi has reached this
conclusion that there is a God without
the imprints of any society any
religious teachings he has basically
reached this enlightened state all by
himself
the reasoning and inspection of the
world it was not by chance that this is
sometimes referred to as the self-taught
philosopher as arguably one of its main
themes deals with the potentiality of
enlightenment in every human being
now once high realizes that there is a
god he desperately wants to get closer
to this this higher aspect of reality he
sees himself and his body as connected
to three different realms the mundane or
imitation of the animals
if you will the celestial realm of the
heavenly spheres and finally the
immaterial world of the necessary being
it is at this stage that even two fails
interest in Sufi teachings really come
across as a lot of the practices that
high
now takes on are clearly inspired by a
lot of Sufi teachings firstly in what
appears to be an almost modern
preservationist attitude he has a kind
of benevolence towards all things in his
mind everything in the world has a
god-given purpose every animal and even
every inanimate object in the world has
a sort of it exists for a specific
reason and to interpret that thing's
path to sort of fulfill its purpose that
is to sort of disturb the very nature of
things or God's plan if you will
therefore he doesn't kill any animals
and even refrains from sort of hurting
any plants in any way in the words of
the author all these he was certain was
the work of that necessary existent
being feeding on them would unavoidably
cut them off from their fulfillment and
prevent them from achieving their
intended purpose now initially he
decides that no I'm not gonna eat
anything at all he doesn't eat a neat
animal he loves me any plants but he he
quickly realizes that this isn't a very
healthy option because it will kill him
basically he will die from hunger and so
and that will defeat his purpose on
earth and so he compromises by deciding
to eat certain plants but only just
enough for him to survive and nothing
more but secondly another part of his
being is connected to the heavenly
spheres so he starts imitating their
movements by moving in circles himself
on the island to become as similar to
them as possible
various you know this of course reminds
us of certain super practices and even
the very famous whirling dervishes of
the Mevlevi order in
that is based in Turkey and finally he
imitates the necessary being by sitting
in his cave and simply contemplating and
after a long time of doing these
practices he finally at the age of 42
has a direct ecstatic experience of the
divine that is described by the author
in a very striking language he describes
the vision as being of 70,000 faces each
of which with 70,000 mouths
each of which with 70,000 tongues all of
them singing God's praises even to fail
does however strictly warn against any
literary interpretation of these words
as he sort of really stresses the sort
of indescribable nature of this mystical
experience and so finally after all
these years of contemplation and
investigation hai has reached the
ultimate point of enlightenment and he
spends every waking moment in seclusion
from the physical world and in
contemplation of the necessary being now
you may think that the story is over
here but you'd be wrong it actually
takes a surprising turn at this point
when hai is 50 years old and suddenly
runs into another human being for the
first time you see in a nearby kingdom
there are two individuals named abyssal
and Solomon and these two live in a
society that follow a religion that
isn't specifically named in the book but
from the descriptions it is pretty clear
that it's referring to Islam a sort of
mainstream version of Islam if you will
anyway both of these men are very
faithful to this religion practicing all
its rituals and reading its sacred texts
and so on however their approach to
religious practice is quite different
Solomon likes to involve the community
in the practice living a life that is
aimed outward focusing on the exterior
aspects of things as it were absol on
the other hand he likes to sort of
isolate himself from the rest of the
world to contemplate
much like hive does and this is his way
of practicing his faith focused inward
rather than outward like Solomon and
this leads up cell to travel to highest
island to find solitude and to meditate
he obviously doesn't expect to run into
any other human being on this island so
when he first encounters hi he is
naturally scared hi on the other hand is
very curious and he runs after him and
after a very dramatic introduction absol
realizes that hi doesn't hat doesn't
speak any language and so being a very
compassionate and kind man he decides to
to teach hi his own language and also
about his own religion and his and his
beliefs but what up cell finds out as hi
is able to talk about his own beliefs is
that hi already knows the truth as it
were he just uses different words and
symbols to explain it an upsell is
amazed at the divine knowledge of this
savage man and decides to bring him back
to his own society it is here when they
eventually get back to upsells' Kingdom
where's his home that high makes some
very interesting observations about
society and especially the role of
religion in society while he recognizes
that the faith in question which is
probably Aslam is true and just he asks
himself what do you need all these
symbols and rituals to express knowledge
of the divine because according to high
knowledge is available in a more pure
form devoid of such metaphors or symbols
but when he tries to talk about it with
other people about his experiences they
don't understand him and they even
reject him as a kind of heretic and at
this point high sort of concludes in a
section that is quite negative towards
common folk of the world that most
people need
and regulatory laws they're basically
too stupid to to receive that the truth
and it's sort of unstained form he
doesn't however think this he doesn't
however think this religion of symbols
is false as I mentioned he does can
think that the message that it provides
is basically the same as what he himself
has discovered on his Island and so he
sort of accepts religion as a as a
necessary evil or a set of necessary
aspect of the world or a society in
general but he and up-sell however they
they they prefer to live in solitude and
so eventually they decide to together go
back to the island and they live out
their days in contemplation of God and
that is how the story ends
so what is it that makes this story so
special now remember this was written in
the 12th century in Marrakesh and some
of its themes and points are incredibly
forward thinking and progressive for its
time I mean even even some of its points
wouldn't feel entirely out of place in
today's world for one thing the book
explores the nature of the human mind
and it presents a theory that in in
perfect conditions all humans can reach
the potential that higher did it is
based on a premise or a concept that we
today know as tabula rasa or the idea
that all humans are born like a blank
page and that all information are filled
in as we experience things in our life
now this is a concept that is usually
traced to another English philosopher
called John Locke who lived much later
in these 17th century now Locke does
deserve credit for being the one to
popularize the idea and also for being
the one to give it its name but when
coming up with it he was likely very
inspired by higher binocs on in fact one
of his teachers was the first person to
translate the original Arabic text into
English and so he was likely exposed to
this novel in other words higher by
Nexon and its author as an enormous
influence on modern Western philosophy
now the idea of table rasa is is a main
theme in the book and at its time it was
very original and innovative in the way
it was presented but like most of the
themes and points in this novel he
wasn't the first to think of that either
in fact the premise of tablet us or the
idea of it was formulated by another man
even before that and that man is even
Cena and to understand the importance of
this man consider the fact that Arabic
and Muslim philosophy is usually divided
into two categories before had been Cena
and after ippon Cena now we know that he
had already formulated the idea of table
and I mean most likely he wasn't the
first person to think of it either but
he writes in the 11th century that human
intellect at birth resembled a table
rasa he probably didn't used that word
but anyway a pure potentiality that is
actualized through education and comes
to know and that knowledge is attained
through empirical familiarity with
objects in this world from which one
abstracts universal concepts and so we
can see here that even Sina already a
century before eben sapphire writes hi
urban oxen had already thought of this
concept of the blank page of the human
being and the influence of have been
seen on higher binocs on is clearly
visible throughout the story from this
concept I just discussed to the very
nature of God as the necessary being or
necessary existence these are concepts
and ideas I could make a whole other
video about but basically if you know a
benzina you'll find them all over this
book and this is also a good moment to
sort of think about the importance of
telling history in a proper way and that
while Western philosophers like John
Locke was geniuses in their own right
the previous thinkers of the Muslim
world for example are often overlooked
in spite of their huge influence and and
sort of contribution to both science and
philosophy and many other fields so even
to fail in this book puts a lot of
emphasis on the value of empiricism and
the scientific method as it's known
today as in understanding the world
through investigation and reasoning he
also in the novel stresses a kind of
individualism that really stresses the
importance of thinking for oneself and
these are both very important aspects of
modern thinking both the very big
emphasis on empiricism and science and
reason but also this individualism
that is one of the core aspects of our
modern thinking today he seems to be
against blindly following tradition or
just doing whatever others have done
before
instead he values the individual who is
able to investigate and think for
himself
hi in the novel is all by himself on the
island and through his investigations
and empiricism he is able to understand
the world and the divine reality without
any imprint of society or without any
religion that he follows he simply does
it through his individual potential as a
human being and that is one of the core
themes of this book and an incredibly
modern way of looking at the human mind
as well as as science and rationalism it
also asked questions that are still
relevant today like in the scene where
the mother dies and like like I think
most of us have asked ourselves this
question what is it that makes you you
and what makes me me are we our bodies
or are we something else and what is
that that seems to leave the body when
we die it's it shows that that 900 years
ago people were thinking about a lot of
the same things that we think about
today
moreover the novel is very interesting
as it seems to have an almost
conservationist attitude towards the
natural world hi he doesn't kill any
animals and he barely touches any plans
as that would sort of disturb their
purpose their god-given purpose in the
world and this is I think of a beautiful
message especially today that it's very
relevant in terms of you know what we're
seeing with climate change and the way
we are treating the natural world
whether or not it should be interpreted
in this way is unclear it mean to fire
after all most likely didn't have any
strong opinions on climate change but
but it is an interesting point
nonetheless even if it'd been tough I
probably didn't have that kind of
message in mine
if you will and finally the story makes
some very striking points about society
and religion and the role of religion
and society it takes an almost
Universalist position and suggests that
religion is just a set of symbols and
metaphors but there's a deeper truth
that can be reached by anyone you know
irregardless of any specific ritual sir
or any imprint from society when to file
seems to take a position where
philosophical inquiry and reasoning is
superior to any religious symbols and
while able to fales points about the
general public can seem very bleak and
negative he's making a points about a
universal truth this reminds me of
something a man once told me that we are
all going towards a specific destination
some choose to use a bike to get there
other use a cars and some maybe use a
plane but the destination is always the
same for all of us is this the point
that I've been to fail is trying to make
in terms of religion and different
religious traditions probably not but it
definitely inspires such thinking in me
and probably a lot of people who read
this book I mean it must have been
rather controversial at the time as it
questions so many aspects of society and
tradition and indeed it wasn't very
popular in the Muslim world at the time
it didn't gain any real traction until
much later in Europe when he was being
translated but at that point it inspired
many thinkers and movements that led to
the Enlightenment and to modern
philosophy inspired other stories like
the famous Robinson Crusoe and generally
has had a really big impact on the world
we live in the statement that it is the
most important story you've never heard
of certainly seems pretty accurate of
course and remember this it is very
important to be careful when
interpreting texts like this and to be
aware of our own backgrounds and biases
and cultures and so on it is very
possible that even if I himself would
find a lot of these readings and
interpretations of the text as very
foreign and completely devoid of
anything he was trying to say that
shouldn't stop us our from finding
aspects of the book that speak to us in
our time and completes our sort of
intellectual curiosity but on top of all
this remains a really well-written piece
of literature and an interesting and
very valuable historical artifact that
really synthesizes most of the schools
of thought at the time I've been seen as
metaphysics and psychology
Aristotle's matter and form alpha
hobbies astrology and and the medical
teachings of Galen oh and as well as the
sort of Sufi ecstatic visions of the
Sufi tradition the book is a kind of
perfect photograph of this intellectual
moment in time that can also stand on
its own as a profound and
thought-provoking philosophical tale so
what do you think is this premise
possible can a man alone on an island
still reach intellectual highest like
the main character does or is this just
wishful thinking if not then do you
still think the story makes some
interesting philosophical points about
human nature and and what do you think
about its views in society and religion
leave a comment and tell me what you
think and thank you for listening
[Music]